are you
ready hello everyone welcome to the
class all and audience online good to
see you all uh it was a fantastic I only
got the last five minutes of it but it
was a fantastic uh um lecture by Julian
thank you that was very beautiful I'm
going to use this game in the future for
my students that was that was fantastic
hello hello everyone so today I brought
this one on Sunday we reviewed some of
the positions and Julian and I realized
that we suck at chess so we are going to
continue that that one position with the
pawn with let me just show you this one
guys uh and I'm going to create a study
then that was something
else yeah and this one we had in in
puzzle paradise and uh uh which one was
that oh yeah this one where was it
no yeah here we realize that we suck at
chess we was think okay D4 is the key
idea capture and then we just go then
then and then uh Queen takes
H5 and then Queen takes D1 check and
wins seems very easy done deal and then
D4 there's there's
B5 and if we take there is G2 and if we
don't take then there's B4 and then we
realize that uh
you know I should bring a mat next time
Ben and every time I realize I suck at
CH I should I should do 10 push-ups
that's good that's good for my health
that's a great idea huh I can start with
today maybe two push-ups per per sure
per that okay now okay um we continue on
with the Rook endings
mhm jul you okay with
that actually you know what I want to go
back to the bishop in games that was
very fun
so uh let's just start
easy and uh the book is as usual again
let me show it anging Labyrinth by uh
aard I really love this book and
uh I I have I have the endgame data uh
the endgame study database by I think
it's I bought it it's like 100,000 in it
or something but you see these are all
just files but this book has you know
been selective and you know put in a
good order for you so highly recommend
it end game Labyrinth it says grandm
training but anyone can do it I think
anyone above 1800 is this is a good book
for them you can benefit from that okay
let me uh move this around a little
bit and start okay start easy huh let's
start
easy
this is Julian this is one star
so it is it is is this is very scary
so if I get this one wrong I'm going to
do 10 push-ups right away
here all
right
resignation
and all these positions are from that
book
yes oh big big blunder on my part sorry
King is on C1 that makes a huge
difference
okay oh yeah makx two of
us all right
okay what am I missing
here
okay actually this wasn't that easy it
is not that easy actually you found it
no I have an idea I have an idea I found
the idea but it's still I have I'm
working on the idea guys
just uh somebody freaked out tomorrow is
already 10th dude somebody says that's
from Big Labowski actually I'm
seeing already the 10th so King
D1 that's on the the chat it could be
the
10th
King
D1
king2
yeah got it all
right hello everyone hello online we
don't have anyone saying any answer Ben
or I'm am I missing something no I think
they're just thinking they're thinking
yes it's just as hard that's rule number
one it's tough this one is tough no but
I I found the solution King D1 H3 right
King F4 King I mean makes no sense H3
Bishop E1 now if H2 Bishop G3 check King
F4 King E2 H2 Bishop
A5 are youing seeing chats in now from
the top some I see some some's coming
here I'm here for the experience yes I'm
here for the experience King D1 yes King
D1 the new ones are B yeah and Bishop
yeah and Bishop A5 at the end because
now we have a Checkmate on
C7 does that sound does that sound real
to you let's just see the answer guys
so Eland the patzer
calculated King D1 okay there's no other
meaningful move other than H3 we want to
promote the H pawn bishop goes to E1 so
if H2 we have this check uh King F4 is
forced other than that we're just right
we have to play the king F4 King E2 uh
yeah has to push and then Bishop to
A5
mhm it's a Checkmate let's just see if
uh if Jacob with a lot of A's uh
confirms Bishop even double exclam
double xam o o nothing robs one Eagle
like
that double
exclam all right next
one uh
okay this seems very
very similar to things I've seen in the
past
so yeah why to play this one why to play
okay so someone says one push-up every
time would be enough for me to turn into
what is AR is some some bodybuilder or
something maybe like short ah yeah short
yeah well that's not going to happen
don't
worry
you never know
yeah I have a feeling that it's kind of
that that mate with the bishop E7 King
on C5 it is kind of reminder of that one
the
idea I don't even have an idea someone
says Ah that's you aard phobic okay the
book scares me that's a good one that's
a good one Sarah yeah aop
phobic opposition King B5 King I push
the pawn okay these are out of these are
out of out of character completely so
I'm going to I'm going to skip the
comments doesn't help what are we trying
to do actually it says oh winning
completely
winning yeah for the right
position I can't even get the starting
move
here no well I mean it feels like one of
the two Bishop's moves should be start
start starting but it's just a pawn goes
forward
yeah Bishop F6 of course Bishop
F6 because A3 want to go Bishop d8
check King A4 Bishop B6 that's winning
King B5 is the
move Bishop B6 King
C4 okay so Bishop d8 check King B5
that's the position now now we're going
from
there and this is why to play and I
think the starting move is Bishop F6 A3
Bishop d8 check King B5 and then Bishop
D6 Bishop B6 then King C4 that's where
we are at I
think
and then King C6 that's it King
C6 A2 Bishop A2 Bishop
A5 and that's
mate
uh-huh so well let me see there must be
some other counterplay there could be
some D3 somewhere along the
way so Bishop F6 A3 Bishop d8 check King
B5 or King B4 doesn't matter Bishop B6
well you can't put your King on4 right B
we should be seven chick right right
right right so King B5 is forced Bishop
B6 King
C4 King
C6
a no D3 take take Bishop A5
right there there must be some some some
tricks there there must be some tricks
there some
some
no I don't see any tricks
actually it has two
stars so I was looking for why wondering
how to how to stop that pawn it's a good
question I think I figured it out I
think so why's playing it's always why
playing unless I emphasize blacks to
play every position in the book's
composition right or no are white unless
emphasize as black yeah everything you
always assume it's white to
move
so what's cooking I think it's Bishop F6
this is the line I'm looking at so it's
Bishop F6 A3 uh Bishop d8
check
uh so any of these moves like this is
just over right I
mean this is
like the sun us came out so let's so
King B5 Bishop B6 do I miss something
here am I missing something
here this is
forced this is
it is there some sort of
a
no A2 we go Bishop A5 that's what it is
and now we want to go Checkmate
here don't
see okay let's see what what's what aard
has for us Sarah is falling asleep
that's
good the only one who's not falling
asleep is is Ben so Bishop F6 A3 Bishop
d8 cheick King B5 Bishop B6 why double
exclam I don't know he he wasn't that
generous with that with that A6 one with
two stars so Bishop B6 King C4 King C6
A2 Bishop A5 yeah apparently I'm rolling
today it's because of that game Julian
showed earlier huh I'm just just pumped
it's all it's all on on Julian Ben you
see no no you don't see of course you
don't see I I just why would I assume
that You' see I sit here in silence uh
not calculating anything it's all it's
all you it's all
you Ben run for his for his life
realized that I'm picking on him at
every every single second
so all right this is why to play and
wins seems very fun okay guys let's have
a look at this one two
stars two
stars
probably
for
okay
uh let's
see so obviously it's not B takes A6
some sort of a B6 somewhere must must
be only
looking
yeah oh someone said I said ba6 is not a
move guys I can assure you ba6 is not a
move here
A6 is trying to lose right what's that
A6 is trying it's trying to lose at
least he has King B6 to make a draw if
he wants to draw so P6 is not a
move it's a good attempt at losing
though you're right yeah think might
suceed H might
succeed it's close but there's one thing
uh the right
color yeah I mean you probably won't
lose B6 you won't lose it's very hard to
lose that one right color you're right
it's the right color no but you how do
you want to make progress there
no
no you mean your opponent will figure
out not
you yeah you don't figure out I mean you
just will be offered the paved
path King B3 everyone says King B3 is
the first move comes in mind
um yeah King B3 Bishop B4 Bishop B3 Che
check right King takes B5 C4 check
obviously King C6 loses so King
A5 and now we are having some sort of a
mate we
don't and then you
go and and then this is zuk
Zang
it's
not it is not a
z King B3 Bishop before C3 no but if
they go people think okay let me explain
this one to people if we go here here C3
Bishop
A5 and then people
say
uh take on C3 no they don't they go just
can go Bishop
A5 um you know people say how to
approach these kind of puzzles just
think about if it's a real game and use
common sense use common sense really
that's like B takes A6 is not common
sense right you don't want this is not
the first move that you should consider
in this position Common Sense also tells
you that this should be the first move
now B6 is surely not common sense
because he goes King C6 and then your
your your pawns are on a silver platter
excuse my language for not for not being
able to put in a better
way so what I've been trying to make
work
ising3 before uhhuh
B3
c
um C4 A5 and then Bishop
G5 because if you take D6 and I go
bishop d8 and you go B6 and I come back
then you know like Bishop Bishop B4
then2 yeah check Bishop is sort
of
annoying oh other stuck I've been trying
to make that
work it's not easy
though two two two two
star it's it's the king must be getting
mated somewhere along
the at on the edge of the board so King
B3 Bishop B4 Bishop B3 check King takes
B5 C4 King
A5 Bishop G5 Bishop
D6
B6 yeah Bishop
to
H4 should
be we'll always have two squares right
Bishop
oh G5
Bishop Bishop
G5 Bishop H4 Bishop B4 Bishop G5 Bishop
E1 is forced right sorry so Bishop B
okay guys I'm going I I'm say very
quickly here King okay King B3 Bishop B4
King B5 C4 King to A5 Julian said Bishop
G5 very strong move which I actually
missed Bishop takes D6 Bishop d8 check
B6 Bishop back H4 for you want to go
Bishop E1 Checkmate so they have to go
Bishop B4 they cannot play B5 because uh
there's Bishop d8 back Checkmate so
Bishop B4 Bishop G5
now yeah Bishop B1 okay they want me to
draw Arrow so this
this this this this this very strong
move bishop4 check B6 oh sorry not
that this this check this this this
this
uh this check this back to H4 back to B4
which Bishop G5 B1 then Bishop E1 is
forced and here I'm going to go Bishop
to
F4 now I cannot put in zuk it's a draw I
cannot put you in
Z try to make work you always two s yeah
all right doesn't
work
so serious trash looking is happening
out there
guys right I I hear I hear some Ben
maybe you want to go record them there
will be more interest in the trash
talking happening
outside no Ben I'm not disputing that
you're not disputing that boring Elan
sitting there striving some intellectual
achievements which is which which
amounts for
nothing I mean seriously doing end game
puzzles is such a such a fun thing and
it's it's really a in my opinion a great
intellectual
pursue
C I see people are saying camera on
trash talking please come on put camera
there they don't want to see me they've
seen enough of
me so
uh King
B3 here I should go like like uh War
aoan try kill it stop slowly don't don't
don't rush it people are just want to
move
on B6 is not the zuk here B6 King C6
we're losing
[Music]
so you have an answer Sarah
no okay
um I'm going to check the answer no I'm
not going to check the
answer I don't want to check the answer
but I I don't want our audience to get
bored are the audience are getting bored
H I'm not bed okay good so sorry is not
bored so we're doing
good C2 push at some point yes I have to
push that push that cpon at some point I
just
um don't see
it
mhm Julian's back
back so you're back to off your game huh
we'll
see yeah I know the answer
obviously okay so people are asking that
they want they want the camera on the
trash talking happening outside so they
don't want to watch people in the
audience yeah that's I I actually agree
with that yeah hardwired down for this
class okay let's do that and I can I can
join them and I can join them for the
trash talking I'm sure roll the camera
out look I can take I can take the my
phone out even and put ndi and bring the
bring the video in here but my phone is
like dead it's on 1% I can't charge it
how can you be the tech person and your
your phone be on 1% everything is
horrible right
now and and it's not even the 10th yet
man not even the even the 10th yeah and
he hasn't even watched the movie The B
Labowski I mean how can you not have
watch the b leowski b this is also true
but you are 20 something you're not his
age he has he had to watch this I've
seen you've seen yeah come on come on
give me give me a high five come on come
over here give me high five good job
come on come
on come on there we go I
about
yeah yeah there we go there we go good
good on you Sarah good good job we have
we have another one here
rolling
and Ben yeah you haven't watched the
movie yet
huh friends like friends like this
Larry ah that was Gary actually in the
movie forgot it says friends friends
like this
scary come on is this on chest bace no
this is on Lees by the
way and it's a free study so you can
just
clone it if you want and I cannot see
the
answer so one of the things Ben doesn't
know that in this position you kind of
have to listen to your pieces and abide
and that's the core of core value of the
big Labowski you have to abide but what
the position is asking you to
do is every class going to be 10
references I don't understand yes yes
that's me that's when you run into a
fanatic of a classical chess and the big
leowski
what a combo what a combo
yeah yeah the most hated combo in Chess
World
probably it's like it's like your
opinion now you see so you you know some
part of it that's that's very important
that's just like your opinion man people
keep saying B6 B6 just goes King C6 and
then aren't they like cheating so B6 is
the answer right it cannot be the answer
come on King C6 I mean I can I can
assure you this
one so someone someone Someone among our
audience his or her phone has 2% been I
mean you cannot even beat anyone in that
I mean that's
just hey it gets on to that kind of
percentage it's all the same
M ah but someone's right in the audience
King B3 Bishop B4 not B A6 take Bishop
E3
check that is oh my God now Bish should
be three check King B5 C4 King A5 and
now we are here oh my God you have two
diagonals now oh that's so dumb yeah
you're right and now and now and now c4
King let me see we go Bishop
where and now Bishop G5 yeah yes and now
Bishop G5 that's it oh my
God we're pretty done yeah okay I'm do
you want me to do 10 push-ups can you
can you get the 10 push-ups I'm doing
because I am literally really dumb bro
I'm going to do 10 push-ups okay let's
go for it Let's do let's good okay if I
did 10 push-ups every time I got a CH
problem I'd be
jacked okay that I'm not I cannot do
pushups here what do you want me to do
this I mean it should be up down there
yeah that's fine what where where you
want to go here okay yeah let take this
up
okay here yeah sure
that's 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
12 some bonus huh why why H got to go
all the way
down okay at least I tried okay cheating
according to him sounds
good would yell at me for an hour if I
push-ups like that what's that who would
who would Aon would yell at me for an
hour if I who he's
a
okay well you know what he helps me I'm
not I'm not I'm not doing I'm not trying
to be jacked or
anything I cannot even do it
okay okay guys the answer
is no that wasn't hard
actually I'm just trying to
remember it's so dumb I feel soid this
let me just make sure that yeah that's
so so dumb
two okay and that's just
yeah okay I mean it's
just oh boy okay now if I miss things
like this again I should do another
push-ups and then okay just I'm cheating
or not cheating whatever better than
nothing
h oh
well
okay okay let's do
that uh no this is a
draw but it's a hard one okay let's do
that why to player makes a
draw I think you know doing the push-ups
helps actually I think I'm going to do
better from now
on we'll see we'll
see okay I did zero push-ups I did some
physical activity okay fine that didn't
qualify as a push-up fine that's that's
okay he does push-ups in his
streams okay okay here it's I think it's
a shouldering right the only thing I
don't understand what happens if I just
go King C4 and go after the pawn going
to ask why isn't this easy and the
answer is always it's impossible
so ah Bishop E7 C6 F6 Bishop f8 that's
the
problem so King C4 you play Bish E7 D
but King D5 is is a draw I mean the
thing is let me see whose turn it
is no what I'm saying is
that yeah that's the position I don't
understand looks very
simple King C4 no I mean King C4 Bishop
B7 King
D5 King what's that King B5
yeah what D5 makes a difference I don't
know
just ah King B5 C5 okay that's the
problem now now we got it Bishop E7 C5
oh yeah actually so King D5 is actually
important so oh no it doesn't
matter King C4 Bishop B7 you see my
brain is working better now
just King C4 Bishop B7 K C4 King
no but King King C5 yes
then King King C C6 and then you take my
pawn and then I push the F PA sack the
F1 and win the C7 so he has to go Bishop
E7 C5 that's his only way of playing for
a
win so King C4 Bishop E7 King
D5
C5
K
E6 Bishop
f8 only so uh Black's defense is this
this one guys oh sorry Black's uh
Black's way of playing for for a win is
like this and if you go King C4 Bishop
E7 so they want to go C5 the moment we
go forward they want to Counterattack
with the attacking the pawn on
C2
so
okay
um King C4 Bishop B7 King B5
C5 or King D5
C5 F6 Bishop King 6 King B2 C4
there
ah
King wow guys this is cute King C4
Bishop
E7 King D5
C5
F6 Bishop f8 King E6 King B2 right King
B2 makes sense right King
F7 Bishop H6 King G6 Bishop F4 King F5
and you keep chasing the bishop
around
you with me
Julian someone's brain is
hurting so guys the line I'm saying is
that King C4 Bishop E7 that's the only
way he can support this C Pawn on C5 and
also cover the square f8 so the bishop
covers this square and covers f8 score
as well then after they move King C4
Bishop E7 you go King D5 they must go C5
right otherwise we go King C6 we just
covered that with Sarah so King C4 King
D5 C5 I go F6 they move Bishop so after
F6 the bishop is defending the pawn on
C5 taking on F6 would be a draw so
Bishop f8 is forced and then I go King
E6 oh I cannot play King E6 because it
Go C4 I cannot go King E6 because it Go
C4 and the bishop has a diagonal so I
must go C4 so I must go C4 Bishop King
goes to B4 and now I go King
E6 and after the king takes on C4 King
F7 and then I keep chasing the
bishop yeah okay okay Ben Simon I'm a
genius come on can I PST that one just
right away come on go on for it Ben I
know yeah okay yeah Ben knows not B Ben
this is all because of that you know
physical activity just suddenly it just
kicks in
this this
impossible around
yeah let me see yeah I agree Bishop E7
King D5
C5 F let me see
F6 F6 has two points actually F6 which H
C4 and then King chases
wow
okay how fast M would have solved this
probably in two minutes one and a half
minute probably Magnus he might have
seen it already he might have seen it
already and then the king would be
chasing all around lovely idea that's
nice I haven't seen this pattern
before I think it reminds me I've I've
seen the pattern there is
a let me see from where I got this one
the King was chasing The Rook to a draw
you you do you do a pawn push and then I
saw it in dorki where the king the king
traps The Rook on between E5 E8 h8 and
H5 so there are pawns and then the king
keeps Chasing The Rook goes King F7 Rook
is on h8 there's a cannot go to d8 it's
blocked so it goes h8 H5 E5 and they
keep keep King keeps chasing it I said
in de's book and uh
and it kind of that's that's kind of
transpired into chasing here because
I've seen it
before H never made it through that
which one he has
manyame manual no no it wasn't the end
game manual it was a in different book
it's was like a puzzle book or
something
so un un promotes under under promotion
under
promotion okay this one uh
okay why to play oh yeah white to play
and
wins uh okay somebody asked in the
previous one does black have to play C5
yes because if black doesn't play
C5 we go King C6 when the bishop comes
here we push the F sack the pawn uh the
bishop has to capture it and then uh we
win the oops can throw an arrow and then
we take on C7 okay here why to
play pH R maneuver
probably uh Tempo
winning
well somebody has composed his studies
so that's where they come to to be a to
existence some un paid Soul who actually
devoted his life to these things
so all right um I have a line so King D7
probably you should play the move E5 but
you can also try King E4 you play King
D4 I will play
B6 so which which move you start with
King
D7 actually maybe people
smart I mean my problem is they all can
transpose that's my plan to they all can
transpose in Mya again what's that
you're Meda
what is meating can't do that
what no I'm not mitigating the thing is
that B6 I was looking at B6 is the force
move Bishop E4 and King to
D7 yeah mhm so that's what king B4 uhhuh
and then I was thinking King
D6 King B5 King
E5 Bishop
C6 h h
yeah but just at the end he has Bishop
E8 that's the problem H4 King
B6 H5 King Bishop E8 and that's a
draw we one tempo
short I mean in the game everybody play
B6 I think B6 must be the solution you
want to avoid any sort of Sidelines or
anything if I see everything is similar
you choose the most foring one so I will
go with
B6
h
feels quite impossible
actually
ah what what's wrong with King e E7
actually what do we do against King
D7 well that's what I'm looking at right
now but again what what about King F7
and King D7 because they still are the
same so King E7 King B6 King B4 B6
Bishop
E4 you're saying B6 Bishop D4 and then
you want to play King E7 there this no
King D7 all looking the same it's white
to move guys but King D7 takes away C6
right right now the problem is that what
what do you want to do after Bishop E4 I
mean King King D7 King B4 B6 Bishop E4
no no no B6 bishop4 King D7 King
B4 looking at
H4 King C7 King
C5 King
C7 E5 h five wins yeah
so okay there should be a catch
somewhere we're missing
it so B6 Bishop E4 King D7
E5
y King D six King
B4 King takes
E5 bish Bop C6 Bishop no not bishop6
Bishop B7
Bishop Bishop anywhere king6 right and
that's it yeah I
just do I I should King A5 King C7 King
A6 yes you just win you put the King on
C7 push the H Pawn uh well I was more
concerned with him going the other way
but he's
outside so B6 Bishop Bishop E4 King D7
huh that's what I was
thinking okay um I'm not
confid let's check it
huh Sarah seems bored a little bit
no it's
B6 Bishop E4 King D7 Bishop D5 what's
this
King
C7 oh my God oh my God it's just we
didn't see any of the counter
play
WoW wait so can6 here yeah okay it's
easy it's easy but we didn't see this
line uh and then you take and then you
promote and give a check on
G3
yeah four star for this one I'm sorry I
don't buy
it all right and last
one
draw
mhm I think his PL to play King H4 and
uh move the
bishop so guys for those who are
listening online King wants to go here
and he wants to move the bishop then you
don't have G3 because this King
H3
so we have exactly one legal so I
think we have two legal okay it's one of
twoes that much I know it's either King
C7 or King
C5 can't move your Bishop because I go
on the diagonal and make a
queen can't put your King on a light
Square because I check
you
C7 or
C5 C5 makes sense huh C5 King G5 King D4
King H4 King E3 so that
works he's like maybe his plan isn't
even to like go King H4 he's just trying
to um box you like King C5 King
E5 and force you to a light Square
so it's
uh
king6 oh so it's a case of zuguang
actually so it's it's an opposition it's
an opposition play
king7 C7 yeah King E5 um no King C7 King
G5 so King C5 must to be it has to be
king C5 King King G5 we we're on time so
black must go yes people are saying on
the chat too people must go King
E5 he can't go to F4 because G3 so that
is a line
Square King has no
move
we have to choose between
B6 his only okay uh his only plan is to
play King H4 he cannot win with the King
on
E1 he only wins if he plays King H4
right so if I go King C5 King E5 you can
just go you play King A5
I play King C5 I
win you are in we are in zuku yes so we
have to not fall for that so King C5
King
uh King King C King C5 King
E5 you can't afford going to A8 though
A8 A7 you can play so King C5 King E5
King
B6 if he goes King F4 it's not possible
King F6 back you go King C5 so King B6
King King D6 King A7 King
C5 k b a king
b8s king D4 King C7 King E5 oh shoot we
lose
no yeah so King C7 King E5 King E5 King
B6 King
D6 King A7 King
C5
I mean you don't have a move there right
no you did something
wrong but now of those days
dude
yes why can go to A8 but then the king
runs back to H4 that's the
problem
wait so hold King King C55 King D6 King
D6 King A7 King C5 King C5 king
a king A8 King
uh King
D4 I was just trying no King D4 King uh
no King B8 King C because I was trying
to after King D6 to go King d8 and say
it's your
turn you can actually you can do that
you can go King a you're right because
King D4 doesn't do anything King B6 if I
go King D6 you go King B King B8 and
that's a draw because if I go King E5
King C7 King F6 King D6 again so King so
King C5 King E5 King B6 King D6 King A7
King C5 King
A8 yeah you King
D no but King E4 that's okay you can go
King
A7 all right we did it we did it let's
see let's just see if let's see so King
C5 King
E5 King King B6 King D6 King A7 we did
this part correct let's just hope that
we're we're on the right
track King
C7 okay King C7 of course we go King A8
but
if uh it doesn't even look at King C5
it's so easy King a k King C7 King A8
King forces King it's our only legal
move yeah what's what is this talking
about King C7 so King A7 King
C I think they might mean King C5 there
actually King
B6 King
B8 King C5 King
C7 this this okay this is all Force this
is not not much to
learn
okay true I feel I feel like we got that
one yeah we got that we got this fun
yeah but but let's just now use the
engine actually just look at the line
that is actually oh it both doesn't
matter wait but King B8 King D6 how was
that oh King
H7 so he doesn't he's not he doesn't
have oh because he has to go through
around the Mind squares and we're in
time back in position
okay uh somebody says if if they go here
no then we go we go this way just this
doesn't work
go Bishop
G2 all
right thank you guys I'll try to learn
how to push it next time guys but it was
good for my up uplifted my
mood all
right all right take care have a good
one guys
bye
[Music]
h